the Trump administration is making its
strongest push yet for a ceasefire in
northern Syria vice president Mike Pence
and Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
planned to visit with Turkish president
air21 this morning in Turkey's capital
Ankara they're trying to convince Turkey
to halt its military operation against
the Kurds CBS News obtained a letter mr.
Trump wrote to air Dewan last week
asking him to handle the situation the
quote right and humane way he added
don't be a tough guy don't be a fool and
let's make a deal he added retired
Admiral sandy Winnefeld is a CBS News
military and homeland security analyst
he is a former vice chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff Admiral good
morning exactly the one person to talk
to you in a morning like this can the
Vice President and the Secretary of
State actually succeed in getting a
ceasefire done they might be able to get
a ceasefire accomplished who knows
because Iran is a strong man who has his
own domestic political issues and
doesn't want to appear to be weak
but even if they're able to accomplish a
ceasefire there are a lot of other
things that are a problem at the
strategic level with this deal very
unusual letter that the president
apparently wrote to the president of
Turkey the language was odd the the the
posture of the American government was
odd what struck you well when I first
saw the letter candidly I almost thought
it might have been a fake a lot of
people did yeah and you know it didn't
seem to have the gravitas that you would
expect a superpower leader to use when
speaking to an ally who's stepping out
of line yeah but the president's
entitled to his own style it just seems
a little bit President Trump called the
Kurdish fighters no angels you worked
with them for 30 years that would you
describe you know the Kurdish fighters
there's a long history here post-world
War One they were guaranteed a homeland
they've been betrayed many times ever
since we began our closest relationship
with them in 1991 when we sent them
humanitarian aid after the first Gulf
War and they never forgot that and
they've been very loyal allies and
friends since have supported us in
numerous operations in Iraq and now
they've been fighting and dying to the
tune of 11,000 Kurds who have
essentially been working on the ground
against Isis who is a sworn enemy of the
United States
he also said though that the Kurds are
safer now what's your response to that
well president several hundred Kurds I
think have been killed in the last few
days the initial phases of this
incursion I I don't believe that I could
credibly say that the Kurds are safer
now when you hear the president say
listen this is their war we need to get
out of there I'm sick of Americans dying
over there let them handle their own
battles what do you say to that when
you're trying to take on a terrorist
organization it's a long-term operation
and so the important thing is to make it
an economy of force operation where you
find a partner on the ground who's
willing to fight your enemy and you
support them perhaps with some Special
Forces with a lot of airpower
that's economy of force and you have to
sustain that if you're going to win
something can we fix this effectively
it's gonna be very difficult to fix this
it's essentially irreversible because
the the territory that we're leaving is
very rapidly gonna be filled in by
Syrian forces that are supported by Iran
ian's and Russians and the Kurds have
switched their alliance over over to
that so it's essentially irreversible
the one thing we can only hope for is
that they will continue the fight
against Isis so that the Middle East
Europe and of course the United States
can could always send troops back in
that might reverse it could that happen
I don't think that will send troops back
in unless perhaps there were a major
terrorist attack against the United
States or a close ally that ground is
gone now we handed it over for free Wow
all right Admiral sandy Winnefeld always
good to have you at the table thank you